je suis vidé je suis très heureux d'être
là ce soir parce que c'est une date
particulière puisque c'est le 23
septembre
que gilles verdez a mis son kiki la
première fois
alors alors alors je vais vous dire
on va pas se mentir c'est mon
anniversaire babre
[Applaudissements]
oui
ce matin à 10 heures il y allait à
travailler avec moi qui me dit tu es en
tt 1 qu'est ce que j'ai dit encore comme
au keirin annoncé pour ton anniversaire
choix oui combien de tweets soixante
mille tweets
non mais vraiment voilà et donc ce soir
pour mon anniversaire bien entendu il y
aura des
vous ne savez pas du tout ski manière il
y aura des cadeaux
pour gagner ces cadeaux ça va se passer
maintenant non et non
de pépins et kylie kylie gan vie nous
qui mais gagne c'est nous illégal c'est
en tout cas une chose est sûre c'est que
vous vous ne gagnerez rien vous êtes
déjà assez payé pour ne rien [ __ ]
comme c'était mon anniversaire vous êtes
12 autour de la table aujourd'hui je
peux vous le dire et je le dis aux
téléspectateurs je perds de l'argent
[Rires]
[Musique]
le jour de mon anniversaire je suis en
mesure de le dire je fais cette émission
à perte
car quatre chroniqueurs en plus ça me
fout un trou
je vous le dis je fais trois émissions
comme ça il ya trois fois mon
anniversaire ma saison on met la clé
sous la porte et production cool oui on
est en sous main on est passé par les
états unis
ce que j'aime dans cette émission
j'adore rire mathieu de remila gueuler
parce qu'on était trop il a dit à trop
de chroniques aujourd'hui on est 27 est
pas là
malheureusement matthieu delormeau qui
n'a pas été sélectionné
dans l'ombre à semaine et on lui
souhaite bien entendu un mot à m
je sais qu'il est en hammam à cette
heure est-ce que vous avez des choses à
dire oui alors on va aller dire dans un
instant
et oui les chiffres il ya un jour il a
des invités qui rappelait bernard
montiel où elle est née dans la cabine
téléphonique à les y aller
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant ça ça nous allait avoir
alors je vous dis je il aura dix
secondes pour trouver qui est la
personne qui me souhaite bon
anniversaire s'ils les trouvent à chaque
fois laura canaux pour le bruit
capannelle personnes soit permettra là
les fidjiens le connard à l'eau
le téléphone et marchissy
on a payé on est en étant 5g
ça normalement ça moche mais là on
entend y avait pas mal a pas de retour
à l'huile encore il doit deviner qui si
ils ne savaient que ce jeu est une
méchante
c'est en terminer 2010 je suis alors
dit la compagnie créole donc c'est la
compagnie club qui me rend assez la
pelzgasse excusez moi est ce qu'on va la
synthèse c'est la compagnie créole qui
me souhaite la bonne anniversaire même
alors pas donné mais moi
oui moi alors oui bonjour ne fait plus
rien montiel tt tt nul comme quand tout
à coup
ce truc là et d'abord il faut fermer la
porte quand on est d'accord
mais
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est au
thorax r2d2
bizarre il est à l'appareil à l'eau tu
vois que c'est bizarre
[Applaudissements]
non c'est quelqu'un qui est à l'article
de la mort il est à l'hôpital à queneau
honnête si c'est que alors c'est mais en
plus vous êtes là donc je vois pas
avant
les chéris essayer de caler un est ce
que vous avez fait des répètes
d'ordina à pied tall à l'oral ici on va
essayer de trouver de qui il s'agit d'un
saut bonjour je viens
moi j'ai trouvé direct qui m'était qu on
and on fait ça et l'autre sur belfort
tuba sans rien
moi je dis je le crains tu m'as fait la
compagnie créole jean-luc sétois motivé
[Applaudissements]
m
excuse moi jean-luc chez les personnes
très âgées avec moi qu'ils entendent
très mal
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
je t'aime fort mon jean luc merci de
m'appeler et me séry l'anniversaire à
toi je te fais un gros bisou bravo pour
tes résultats qui tombe cette année un
amour jean luc et toi aussi je vois je
regarde les audiences tous les matins et
d'ailleurs je t'envoie souvent et petit
sms c'est incroyable il est peut-être
plus du double sur le deuxième mais
on se gausse qui l'année prochaine bona
libertaire je suis en tournage dans le
sud des géniales sur mater ce fait un
gros bisou
l'échiné
les chéris je voudrais vous dire un truc
on va changer les règles du jeu car
c'est de la merde je le savais c'est une
aide pour dean qu'on embrassait c'est
moi c'est mon anniversaire mais c'est ça
fait
c'est très simple on va mettre un
chroniqueur dans la cabine téléphonique
ouais comme ça pour le fun
on va prendre la personne au téléphone
et on va essayer de trouver de qui
s'agit à chaque fois il va y avoir des
personnes qui m'ont appelé si on trouve
toutes les personnes le public on a un
magnifique cadeau entre ailleurs si on
ne trouve pas
si on ne trouve pas tous les
chroniqueurs présents ce soir ne feront
plus partie de l'aventuré
[Rires]
quand tu rentres est à chaque fois on en
sauvera c'est à paris sera dans la
cabine hissant terme et jouent par
amélie sauver ok ce n'est pas qu'ils
aient sauvés alors les séries attention
on va démarrer maintenant il ya une
deuxième personne qui va nous appeler je
vais demander à delphine palais dans la
cabine merci delphine
elle fit jo zosso que tu peux faire mais
la patron comme par hasard tu peux
appeler roger
la padanie de la le même téléphone chez
lui
tue pas mais ton mec attention au
deuxième personne qui nous appelle on a
et je vous le dit chez vous aussi vous
avez est ce qu'on n'a pas un cadeau des
cadeaux pour les téléspectateurs
l'assureur twitter
non eh bah j'en veux pour les
téléspecteurs vous avez une minute pour
tous à
la haye à new delhi magnifique c'est ok
laisse-moi de minutes
mais qui est la deuxième personne qui
m'appellent pour me souhaiter un bon
anniversaire alors sur scène à consommer
on tient concept pour l'instant delphine
et sauver le film fallu merci pas fait
je ne sais qui va bien
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
à
l'aube à amman allô oui oui bonsoir
bonsoir
merci dany qui attendent et on voit si
vous avez déjà trouvé non pas du tout
sis à ouaga sont vides c'est énorme
allez
mon frère d'amour enfin ils gaspillent
de valider sort bientôt il sera des
couleurs 11 octobre d'ailleurs franck
serrano chéri d'amour je suis dégoûté
j'avais plein de petits trucs à dire
j'avais prévu de dire je suis une
personne ou cyril a fait caca dans mes
chaussures qui suis
[Rires]
trop d'amour d'un rebond après rebond
trop longue vie oui juste on n'est pas
passé la soirée ensemble hier soir oui
alors oui
on voit pas de message et or pas de
message qu'on va pas y arriver ces maps
à la bombe à demain demain devant
c'était c'est noté je t'aime mon frère
autres organes et 24 avec nous la
saison 2
elle emprunte je réunis pour le 11
octobre au sujet de valider je pense
qu'on aura une surprise énorme je vous
le dis la saison 2 elle est folle et on
va vous faire une surprise énorme jeudi
avec le groupe canal on prépare un truc
de fou a donc le 11 octobre retenez bien
cette date si vous aimez valider si vous
aimez franck gastambide et je sais que
vous êtes très nombreux plus de 25
milliards contre lui en tout cas voilà
franck que j'aime voilà c'était le
deuxième d'un invité d'accord bon là
delphine c'est bon tu est sauvé merci ça
va tu as pas trop chaud c'est bien comme
truc là mais c'est
vraiment
alors les charlots qui avait si vous
avez des choses à dire avant qu'on ait
un prochain appel est ce que vous le
mettez gâtés je n'ai pas été gâté
j'étais extrêmement gâtés valérie bénaïm
offert ce magnifique bracelet
benjamin castaldi m'a offert le short de
rocky mais non non
nicolas pernikoff
ne fait rien
j'en ai regardé alors maison mais je
vais faire le tour ensuite faire le tour
magenta casting m'a offert je vous le
dis le schork de schork de rocky
mythique je le mettrais d'ailleurs d'un
mauvais acteurs je ferai des missions
avec moi peut-être demain mais ça a
l'airé ben haim tu peux je me suis mis
ta gueule
valérie bénaïm offert un magnifique
bracelet élevé
nicolas pernikoff m'a offert son amitié
[Musique]
j'attends toujours j'espère que ça
arrive maintenant de nouveau le verdict
c'est pas un mal en soi les commandes et
je vais commander
tous 17 sera donc
juste valérie benaïm attention parce que
il ya juste il ya une allumette derrière
vous
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
en allemagne
ce genre d'animation tu les fais ça
c'est morgane g ce que j'adore en plus
le shérif ça te va traire et des biens
scheme uss liberty
canivez novelli m'a offert une casquette
ou à un tee-shirt et un tweet que
j'adore merci à vous merci kenobi droid
je vous connais bien là à oui exactement
franchement là tous les cadeaux qui sont
magnifiques jean michel maire m'a offert
de bien prononcer une phrase
[Rires]
je voulais offrir quelque chose jouer
faire simple et original je voulais lui
offrir un plat pour autre bateau on m'a
dit que c'était plus de 10000 euros
juste
[Rires]
jacques c'est dingue de revenir et on
s'est tous dit rien mais c'est vrai et
lui s'éteint mais vraiment triste
belfin c'est mon amour pour les crèmes
elle m'a offert une crème d'une marque
qui est magnifique une belle crème très
cher magnifique 13 je connais ce que je
connais pas mais je peux vous dire c'est
une crème d'amande à venir et ça se voit
ouais ouais explosé hier
et là tout ce côté là
rien
d'étonnant
à ce que je voulais l'offrir ben dewar
m'a dit non pour le descendre manque je
redescend donc du coup j'ai l'air con
d'accord très bien on va on va regarder
tout à leur machine j'espère bien on
veut voir tommy parce que j'ai quelqu'un
téléphone boxeur je fais des missions et
vous la regardez
[Applaudissements]
je pense
à ma mère si vous
n'essayez pas de les utiliser votre ce à
quoi les cherry on a une autre personne
au téléphone car isabelle hallé matic
pas d'isabelle
changer les règles là je veux qu'on
entende tous et à qu'isabelle qui devine
tués dans la case si isabelle devine
elle fait du bien ça a laissé passer
mais je déteste quand on fait ça si je
perds
[Rires]
jamais
c'est magnifique a se déplace on dirait
doctorat
sur l'économie
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce qu'il a dit
yana qu'après bien appeler si vous
plaidez budget vous allez vas-y sassone
décroche à
l'écouté très bien synchronisés
c
le nouveau guide en 2021 examinateurs
une séquence comme ça
oui on vit avec notre temps oui
messieurs dames oui oui voilà oui à la
technologie sim et nora costa
yakata tu vas te parler c'est le temps
de parler un bateau
oui allô
alors
moi j'ai transformé ma voix parce qu
apparemment vous n'avez pas les moyens
de payer la machine pour transformer des
voix pour l'invité mystère
[Rires]
sorte une oreille
c'est une weed saurait s'arrêter quand
gaston excusez moi mais c'est ce que ça
m'énervait pour faire des courses au
franprix en face alors oui s kanak alors
la claque au téléphone il se trouvait
depuis s'agit alors il est cuit que
quelqu'un est peu adapté parce que j'ai
pas que ça à [ __ ]
des odeurs bouder est-ce que c'est
bouder abarth il
avoue je pense à 12 heures elie semoun
est ce que ces décès j'adore bouder
boudard est un ami
mais je ne tirais modère ce n'est pas
bouder meta pour plus de son sac ses
clefs merci lourdines gad elmaleh gad
elmaleh très franchement que la bonne
réponse on fait quoi
les besoins
garde mon frérot d'amour qui hélas sa
maman chérie écoute ça va super tu
c'était un peu dur en ce moment on m'a
proposé un petit cachet j'ai appelé et
j'ai un doute a tonné laisse moi te dire
d'abord happy birthday ok moi je vais te
dire je vais te dire tu es un vrai ami
et ses tombeurs des et je tends chouette
des centaines déborder comme ça mon coco
ok tu
devrais te fera un gros bisou et dis moi
mon chéri j'ai vu parce que j'ai une
ville que je tisse douce laquelle j'ai
vu de france non mais je sais mais ya
t-il aux particuliers que je ris de ouf
laquelle j'aimerai je sais que tu joues
à bar-le-duc bientôt bah oui exactement
bar-le-duc le 1er octobre demain c'est
la belle forme et bar-le-duc le 1er
octobre grosse grosse le gros gros show
à bar-le-duc et pour commencer par le
duo cette ville je suis comme un oeuf
sur cette ville des hawks et comme on
appelle les habitants de bar-le-duc des
bars et bars et vous
n'en dites moi comment je serai devant
ma mère d'abord il faudrait qu'on sache
alors bah tu sais quoi non mais
j'aimerais j'aimerais vraiment oui tous
les jours
envoyer des gens te voir à bar le duc
est ce que c'est possible oui jusqu'au
1er août nouri jours à bar le duc
héritier mais non pour le 1er octobre
sert tous les jours j'aimerais faire
gagner deux plates formes ardue parce
que je suis fou de cette ville mais moi
je sais que moi je sais ce que tu as à
bar-le-duc mais je ne peux pas le dire
parce qu'on est des millions de gens qui
nous écoutent et je sais très bien
l'histoire qu'a bar-le-duc avec une
personne de bar-le-duc avec bar la
duchesse
[Musique]
garde 6 to b il ya un truc qui va et
vient j'entendais d'aplomb je sais même
pas ton et applaudissent laval n'était
pas faux
gad jeu solide je suis le jeu serait ça
quel jour le 1er octobre andré le 1er
octobre c'est un vendredi et on les
appelle des barisien ou des barisienne
débat rien
on ne dit pas des paris des parisiens
des parisiens voilà bah voila merci
bernard montiel en tout cas bravo vous
guide il est très bien
j'avais quoi tu roules encore votre
fonction de l'émission
ses maîtres à bord ça fait longtemps
qu'on cherche combien de
gamme je suis jeune j'ai très envie d'y
arriver que des libertés vient de
trouver mon chéri est ce que donc je
serais je sans complexe le bar le duc la
première union c'est quoi ce que tu
appelles écoute moi bien avant de
rentrer sur scène à bar-le-duc je
t'appellerai et on fera un direct avec
le public de bar-le-duc tu veux ça
j'aime cette ville et a franchement
aller voir gad à bar-le-duc je sais pas
s'il reste encore deux bassins mais je
pense que le spectacle à bar le duc ne
vienne à le plus beau avec les autres
spectacles c'est à dire regarde le
spectacle de gad est énorme à bar le duc
il va être encore au dessus de celle où
je vais tout donner et à bar le duc mais
tu vas voir tu me diras quand tu seras à
bar le duc tu me remercieras
pas du tout je vous dis qu'on adore
bar-le-duc nous est ce
que j'ai dit
voilà je t embrasse gamme je t'embrasse
je vous aime très
fort débit choquant dans cette histoire
de bar le duc
elle les séries pour l'instant le jeu
est un naufrage
d'autres gens qui m'appellent à
quelqu'un encore qui est prêt qui est là
pour m'appeler
on est dessus
vous avez un message à faire passer ce
soir je vous le dis parce que dans un
instant il y aura le jeudi vérité ça y
est on arrive au bout d'un mois presque
démission et s'est passé beaucoup de
choses avec les équipes avec les
chroniqueurs on aura la boîte à vérité
dans un instant et je vous poserai
toutes les questions ça y est toutes les
questions qui fâchent ne les connais
même pas moi même il y aura peut-être
des questions le concernant les
questions auxquelles je devrai donner
une réponse mais il y aura surtout vous
vous face à la france
1 et donc je vous le dis ça va être
chaud cacao faudra toute la vérité rien
que la vérité la vérité est ce qu'on a
quelqu'un téléphone oui attention alors
on a une nouvelle personne au téléphone
on va essayer de trouver de petits il
s'agit d'accords attention c'est parti à
l'eau bon ça va quoi bon ben moi j'ai
trouvé direct alors vous est ce que vous
avez trouvé c'est une énorme surprise
pour moi puisque je je laime je laime
cela d'or voilà j'en suis fou de lui et
c'est un scanner que j'aime voilà année
sa part a dit non mais alors pour
l'instant t
kenji jean claude van damme ben alors
alors allons-y au quotidien a parlé avec
la personne soir ce que vous savez 1h10
un indice à nous donner
bonsoir aime pas même pas jouer avec moi
pas d'elle
c'est qui votre frigo m non non non
allez dites et patrick bruel à n'importe
quoi lui
ricoh macias
non duquenne du jura des gens il ya des
censeurs
[Applaudissements]
ça ça c'est une surprise parce qu'il
sait que je voulais me didier ça va mon
idée ça va bien merci joyau d'amour déjà
pris qu'est-ce que sa joyeuse
anniversaire tu as un amour caisse
capturer pas d'orage m ouais c'est
qu'est-ce que vous êtes un cône à
questa prévu pour moi un corps de paddle
il le
[Rires]
tas d'amour de m'avoir appelé tu sais
que je t'aime fort et j'organise un gros
match et lorsque je t'explique non non
non parce que je peux tu peux dire un
truc comme didier deschamps c'est le
seul mec qui t'appelle pour jouer au pad
avec lui mais choisis ton partenaire
c'est à dire lui choisi son partenaire
il dit soit tu vas jouer tyga
et sélectionneur dans tout en fait non
non non tu mandat un peu c'est toi qui
choisis ton partenaire est d'ailleurs la
première fois fait t'es pas content dit
la deuxième
la première la première
le téléspectateur
c'est le chemin se fait berner sur la
première didier l'eau c'est le gars m'a
dit qu'il était prof de paddle en fait
il était plus que l'agglo
je t'aime fort embrasse la famille et
continue ce que tu fais voilà tu sais
compter et d'idées c'est un mec
exceptionnel merci mon idée je
t'embrasse fort
[Applaudissements]
bon ça veut dire est une très très très
dévoué à chaque fois de sa wii alors
j'ai joué deux fois avec lui la première
fois j'étais avec un pizzaïolo la
deuxième fois il m'a dit viens jouer au
paddle j'organise tout et il m'a dit
t'inquiète pas je te mets à partenaires
il a gardé le meilleur pour lui
c'est pareil ça prouve l'intelligence du
dynamique et il est très intelligent et
la prochaine fois c'est moi qui vais
l'inviter c'est moi qui m'attendais à
ce qu'on va rigoler je les maîtres
permis quand il va faire
c'est pas très gentil sud vraiment ils
jouent vraiment mieux ou pas non mais
vous non non non possible c'est unique
et il le sait je lui dis je suis bien au
dessus oui malheureusement le paddle ce
jour là deux et je ne sais pas j'avais
beaucoup de mal être des sports
collectifs
les chéri e alors je vous le dis la
prochaine il y as écoutez moi bien un
scooter non on fait gagner un scooter
est un facteur
non mais oh mais nos téléspectateurs
mais non attention assez pour la vallée
nous d'une volée notre vie pour le
paraguay
gagner un scooter
[Musique]
[Rires]
amy et
liturgie bah oui ça date l'a pas fait
ouais ça se fait ce sera toi qui ira
jouer pour le secoue nicolas merci
alors attention là c'est a annoncé qu'
hockey au centre toi nico d'accord alors
attention à l'eau c'est qui c'est parti
on entend la personne alors c'est parti
alors à toi ton à l'heure a sonné ça va
sonner s'apprend forte au téléphone
[Applaudissements]
alors attention à l'eau à l'os et allô
allô allô oui oui dit c'est qui c'est
qui
pronto
[Musique]
pantxo
non bonne chose pour poteau
dans les 10 pôles shoki shoki
antonio colona
[Applaudissements]